New York City is not only home to some
of the greatest comedians on Earth but
it's where many of them were born as
well the Big Apple has set the tone in
the comedy world for a long time now
producing dozens of the most impressive
and impactful Comedians and clubs of all
time Lou see C Chris Rock David near the
top of that list sits one of the most
famous comedy clubs to ever exist the
comedy seller founded in 1981 there's a
good chance that every comedian you've
ever heard of has by the comedy seller
at least once in their career and 42
years later the comedy seller is still
thriving as one of the hottest clubs in
the world and with so much recent hype
around the comedy Mothership it can be
easy for comedy fans to forget just how
popular this New York staple really is
selling out over 80 shows every single
week with this type of demand it can be
difficult for comedy fans to ever get a
chance to attend a show at the seller
but lucky for us one comedian was able
to capture the experience of going to a
comedy seller show and then you sir
Pharmacy business Pharmacy business okay
sounds like drug dealing
uh Mike feny just released a 20-minute
standup special where he not only
performed in each of the sellers four
rooms but also captured some rare behind
the-scenes footage from the shows as
well we recently got the chance to sit
down with Mike and ask him a few
questions about the comedy Seller New
York City and his unique special Mike
feny thank you so much for joining the
show today in your special we got to you
perform in all four rooms at the comedy
Celler out of those four options on a
normal night do you have a favorite and
least favorite room the most popular
rooms are either the village underground
or the original comedy seller location I
still feel like the original comedy
seller is the best room because it's
just it feels like it has the laughter
of 50 years inside the walls there so it
just feels so intimate the the ceiling
so low it just you know it's tiny it
feels like a place that people want to
come hear secrets you said your goal was
to capture what it's like to experience
a normal night of comedy in New York
City and now that your project is
complete a lot of people have seen it at
this point do you think that this
special accomplished that goal I hope so
man I mean I think uh so yeah so far the
feedback has been great I'm I'm excited
that uh people enjoy I also just realize
it's my headphones are green I just
don't have ears it's very funny to just
I was like just noticing this I was like
wait a minute I
years on this um that's hilarious um no
man yeah I mean I hope so I think it's
just it's one of those things where like
as a a lot of people want to come to the
comedy seller you know again it's the
most famous club in the world a lot of
people can't get tickets they sell out
every single show they do so I just
thought it'd be a cool thing because a
lot of times people go what's the
difference between the rooms and stuff I
thought I'd just kind of showcase why
each room looks that way and also as a
comedian like kind of how it feels when
you're just bouncing around like I
didn't want to I didn't want to really
make it like a documentary style thing I
just wanted to show as many jokes as
possible in that and just show kind of
like oh you run into some Comics you
know and there's some other Comics you
know but it's just all kind of imp
passing while we're uh while we're going
to work there was one room during the
special where it started off what you'd
probably call a bad crowd or kind of a
rough crowd but it turned around in the
end how much of a risk is it shooting a
special in front of a random crowd
instead of advertising it to your
specific fans buddy it's one of the
1,00 occupational hazards that came with
this project
because uh yeah dude again and the
problem with that that you're talking
about the fat black bar and the problem
with that was that again I only had one
take at it so anytime anyone films a
special they almost always film two t
two shows so that way they have coverage
with this I did four room so I had to do
double the coverage but there was only
one shot at the bar and as I leave in
the credits you can see uh where Ian
Finance is hosting they are
dumb not all the shows are going to be
great and you know the first I don't
know 11 to 12 minutes of my set I'm just
just taking grenades in the trenches man
just nothing is nothing is hidden uh
it's to the point where I'm thinking in
my head I'm like I mean technically I
could just say I did all three rooms of
the comedy seller in one night and no
one's really going to know that I could
just cut this whole thing I was
literally and then um I got the light to
like wrap up and then I just uh just
happened to talk to the uh the the
couple in the audience who ended up
having a fascinating unbelievable insane
weird story and um and then you know I
got to do the uh the call back to the
kids have and got an Applause break
which getting an Applause break out of
that crowd uh is felt better than any
other Applause break I've ever gotten
because they were so anti seemingly
anti-comedy the fact that I got them to
that level um like Ian was in the back
being like yeah he was just like fist
fing because it was it was really a Hail
Mary buzzer beater it was a great a
walk-off home run I mean it was all of
that in with like literally the last 30
seconds so that was uh that was awesome
to do and I am glad I pulled that out
yeah and with one take too that just
makes the whole story even better yeah
that's what was uh that was what made it
uh that was what made it scary you know
but yeah it's a 20 minute special which
I heard you say the watch time Netflix
is the average viewership of a special
is around that 20 minutes I think it
makes a lot of sense to shorten down a
special but how did you decide what
portions of your hour to include in this
versus what you're holding on to for the
road somebody actually made a great
point in one of in one of the comments
of my specials where they said that um
it reminded them of like the Comedy
Central presents that they grew up
watching which were all again 20 22
minutes eight of commercials like and
that honestly is what I watched growing
up like getting into comedy I watched
more comedy Central presents than I did
hours of Comedy like obviously I watch
like you know Carlin and Seinfeld and
Cosby and like you know like the bigger
guys I watch their hour but so it was
yeah I think it it was it's a good
length to just kind of in terms of um in
terms of like what I chose I just I
decided to just shoot I did again seven
sets so because I ran it all one night
and then I ran it all a second night but
the second night we didn't have a spot
at the Fat Black Pussycat bar so it was
only one take there I wanted to try to
go with something that had like a bit of
a narrative so I did slightly different
sets in each of them there were some
jokes I overlapped twice so I was kind
of like I just wanted to take basically
the whatever the strongest jokes
whatever the best reactions were I was
going to do that and hopefully you know
fit the the through line of the uh of
the special yeah that makes sense all
right last question for you here Mike
and you just mentioned it's the most
famous club in the world I think you
said that at the beginning of the
special as well I don't think many
people would argue that but they would
probably have the top three of the
comedy seller The Comedy Store and now
the mothership out of those three clubs
what makes the comedy seller number one
in your opinion so funny man I've
performed I performed in all three clubs
in the last uh week so it's very funny
to see the you know to see the
difference in them and they're truly I
mean The Comedy Store is also one of my
favorite clubs on Earth um and it was my
first time at the mothership which is
truly an incredible experience I think
with the seller it's just like again man
they got four rooms they 80 shows a week
every when you sell out every single
show a week and it's just and also like
New York City Comedy I mean that there's
so much competition there's so many
other options for comedy in that City
that it's it really does feel like it's
kind of like the you know there's a
reason that Chappelle and rock and Ray
Romano and all the you know these famous
Comics are constantly going there you
know there's there's a bit of magic to
that club yeah that's true I guess you
know they have way more competition than
for sure the mothership and The Comedy
Store as well and they're still putting
up you know all those sold out numbers
that makes a lot of sense speaking of
the mothership though you were just on
an episode of kill Tony uh the episode
came out last week and you witnessed a
golden ticket winner right in front of
your eyes kind of a wild moment what was
that like seeing that unfold live when
Heath walked out on stage I think I'm
visibly seen asking like what the [__]
is going on multiple times um when he
came out man it was just like what the
hell you know jannis said maybe the
funniest thing that nobody heard cuz he
just said it he didn't say it into the
microphone he just said it to me before
Mike finishes that story we need to hear
a quick word from the sponsor of today's
video Underdog fantasy the easiest and
best way to play fantasy sports with the
NBA season ramping up now is your time
to get in on the action with Underdog
fantasies pick them games all you have
to do is pick higher or lower on a
player's stats depending on how you
think they're going to do and if if
you're correct you could win up to 20
times your money in a single night just
by picking correctly on two to five
players stats my picks for tonight's
Celtics Raptors game are lower on Scotty
Barnes and Dennis rer points and higher
on Jason Tatum rebounds if all three of
those picks are right I 6X my money
Underdog is available in 30 plus States
and Canada including California Texas
and Florida so make sure you sign up
today with code joke world and Underdog
will double your first deposit up to
$100 they're also giving joke World
subscribers a special offer of ailable
to new users only with promo code joke
world now back to the video jannis said
maybe the funniest thing that nobody
heard cuz he just said it he didn't say
it into the microphone he just said it
to me he literally just looked at me and
was like what the hell is that thing and
it just was so goddamn funny because
people kep were so torn between like is
he lying about his age what's this
dude's story uh you know and then he was
killing obviously gets a standing
ovation kills um and then like Tony said
was like every question that you asked
him made you think of 14 other questions
you wanted to ask him so I mean I have a
thousand more the fact that he doesn't
know the exact thing that's going on
with him is to me I I still haven't
slept thinking about it would be my only
mission in life I'd be I'd be up on the
Internet 23 hours a day and then the
other hour would be you know jerking off
or whatever but it's uh it was yeah it
was a wild one it was if it was one of
those moments where every all of us
sitting on it like the second it was
over we all looked at each other being
like we just we just witnessed a
legendary uh moment in this Show's
history awesome well thank you so much
Mike for your time today and uh everyone
go check out the special you can find it
on your YouTube channel any other social
medias or upcoming tour dates or
anything uh I am Mike FY on all social
media I got a bunch of dates up at miky
comedy.com and then yeah you can watch
the special uh youtube.com/ mikf comedy
I have my first special Rage Against the
routine up there just uh you know you'll
find me Google me I'm I'm around you
know awesome thanks again
Mike joke
world that's it joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out